vous remercie le président d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et d'être parmi
nous ce matin outre votre fonction
président de l'autorité des normes
comptables vous entendons en qualité
d'auteur du rapport de juin 2019 sur
l'information extra-financière des
entreprises dans la perspective de leur
harmonisation vous avez complété ce
travail par un rapport plus récents vous
avez remis en février 2021 commissaire
européenne aux services financiers
mairead mcguinness ce sujet a déjà été
évoqué par notre délégation à l'occasion
d'un rapport d'information de madame
elisabeth lamure et de monsieur jacques
le nay qui en principe jacques launay
devrait être en visio avec nous en juin
2020 sur la responsabilité sociétale et
environnementale
les pme dont nous souhaitons assurer le
suivi dans ce cadre là d'ailleurs que
nous travaillons ce matin il s'agit là
d'un enjeu majeur de souveraineté
européenne
la bataille perdue des normes comptables
ne doit pas être réitérée commencerait
par une question générale la crise
sanitaire économique at elle selon vous
ralentit les démarches rse des
entreprises françaises s'agissant
maintenant du plan d'action de la
commission européenne en matière de
finance durable
je rappelle qu'il repose sur deux
réglementations majeur
le nouveau règlement sur la taxonomie le
2020 et la directive européenne sur
l'information extra-financière l1 faire
des en cours de révision
en matière extra-financière l'europe
peut revendiquer son avance et même
jouer un rôle de normalisateurs cette
volonté a notamment été exprimé par
secrétaire d'état
livia grégoire à l'occasion du klement
finances des 10 29 octobre 2020 vous
présidez la tasse forte qui doit
formuler des recommandations sur le
standard européen
il s'agit de s'émanciper des normes et
intérêts ce qui constitue le référentiel
comptable applicable aux sociétés cotées
sur un marché européen nous dirait
comment évolue la révision de la
directive sur l'information
extra-financière et dans quelles
conditions une structure européenne
d'élaboration de normes d'information
extra-financière peut se mettre en place
à partir de les frags
qui est le groupe consultatif européen
sur l'information financière
face à cette mise en mouvement de la
normalisation public
le secteur privé ne reste pas inerte
un groupe de travail organisé par le
world economic forum et l'international
de jeunesse quand il a fait apparaître
un livre blanc rédigé par quatre grands
cabinets de conseil proposant un socle
de données le sg de 21 indicateurs clés
par ailleurs les cinq organisations qui
diffuse des principaux standards de
'reporting' environnementaux sociaux et
de gouvernance 10e sv ont décidé de
s'associer et partager leur vision de ce
qui est nécessaire pour construire un
cadre commun de 'reporting'
compréhensible la fondation yves férès
présidée par michel prada a lancé une
consultation sur le reporting
socio-environnemental sustainability
reporting et lé rôle qu'elle pourrait
jouer dans l'élaboration de normes
globales d'information extra financières
sur le modèle qui fonctionne pour les
normes comptables sur le fond vous
pourrez nous confirmer s'il concept de
matérialité constitue l'un des points de
divergence majeure dans cette
compétition entre les visions
américaines et européennes de
l'entreprise les standards
internationaux les intéresse ou du ssb
sont plutôt favorables à ne couvrir que
les impacts environnementaux et sociaux
sur les entreprises
l'objectif premier étant d'informer les
investisseurs sur leur risque de leur
côté européen souhaite baser le cas du
reporting extra-financier sur la double
matérialité qui analyse la fois l'impact
des risques esg sur l'entreprise et
l'impact de l'entreprise sur la société
s'il y est fait reste vague quant au
calendrier les instances européennes
souhaitent que ces nouvelles normes
soient rapidement applicables afin de
mettre en oeuvre le green deal européen
en effet 15 des futures réglementations
du pacte vert pour l'europe dépend de la
standardisation du reporting
extra-financier le sénat d'ailleurs
débattu hier de ce pacte
je vous propose aussi le président
d'intervenir pendant une quinzaine de
minutes pour nous éclairer sur les
enjeux parfois techniques surtout
et toujours en tout cas stratégique
lierse est problématique
ensuite quelques questions de la part
mes collègues sans doute sur ce sujet je
vous rappelle que notre réunion est
prévue pour une heure quel est mixte
avec une partie des sénateurs qui sont
présents ciel que je salue le nouveau et
quelques autres membres de notre
délégation qui sont en visioconférence
cette audition est aussi accessible en
vidéo à distance ce président je vous
donne donc la parole
voilà mais comme la branche et même
avant même que j'appuie sur le bouton
merci beaucoup
donc merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureux
effectivement d'avoir l'occasion de
faire le point sur ce sujet suscite
reçues sur ce sujet clé si l'on fait un
point effectivement à hadath aujourd'hui
l'europe est effectivement en mouvement
donc je commencerai peut-être par vous
faire un point sur l'avancée des de la
question en europe
et puis j'évoquerai aussi les autres
intervenants internationaux afin que
nous mesurions tous je dirais le le la
composition du paysage dans le domaine
de la normalisation extra financière
sur le premier point un gros effort
vient d'être fait une étape vient d'être
franchie et nous aboutissons à une nous
amorçons une deuxième étape le
vice-président exécutif valdis
dombrovskis ce donc de la commission
avait annoncé en janvier fin janvier
2020 donc il ya un peu plus d'un an
trois axes sur la question fondamentale
de la données extra-financières car
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président on peut bâtir toutes les
politiques publiques que l'on veut on
peut bâtir toutes les stratégies privée
que l'on veut mais si la donnée n'est
pas de bonne qualité pour fonder ses
politiques
on est en grand risque d'une part
d'échecs et deuxièmement de c'est à dire
de désaffection des parties prenantes
vis-à-vis de ceux de cette question
cruciale qu'est le développement durable
des entreprises donc l'annnonce du green
deal était intervenue quelques quelques
semaines avant décembre 2019 et certains
dont votre serviteur plaidait en faveur
d'une vraie stratégie sur la donne est
donc le vice-président exécutif a
annoncé trois axes dans le domaine de la
de données extra-financières il a dit
nous allons réviser la haine frd qui
effectivement on dit souvent cela dans
le domaine de la réglementation
financière avait un peu le caractère de
bac à sable c'est à dire de deux de
réglementation un peu expérimentale à
ses principes yale et peu contraignantes
donc il faut passer il faut le élevé la
barre fortement dans ce domaine c'est le
niveau législatif dit niveau 1 au niveau
européen comme vous le savez premier axe
deuxième axe il a dit nous ne pouvons
pas nous contenter de principes de
niveau législatif
il faut des normes pratique pragmatique
robuste et il a ajouté je vais confier
un travail préparatoire à les frags
donc vous avez décrit les
caractéristiques monsieur le président
et troisièmement qui dit norm dit
normalisateurs donc il faut un système
de normalisation et je vais demander au
président de les frags de conduire
de me faire des propositions sur
l'évolution possible de les frags dans
cette perspective donc trois axes
c'était donc il y a quinze mois bon le
coc vide est intervenu donc un peu de
retard mais tout cela a démarré je
dirais à l'été et nous sommes à la fin
comme je vous le disais de cette
première étape 1
le projet de directive a été approuvé
par les commissaires le 21 avril il est
désormais sur la table des co
législateur européen et va suivre le
processus législatif européen que vous
connaissez la prédit que la prédiction
la prévision aujourd'hui est que ce
projet devrait aboutir sous présidence
française
au cours du premier semestre 2022
c'est le temps généralement le temps
habituel pour des réglementations de ce
type
maintenant c'est soumis à tous les aléas
que l'on peut que l'on peut imaginer
donc le conseil et le parlement vont se
pencher sur cette question et il y aura
bien entendu le fameux trilogue avec la
commission pour amender parfaire le
projet qui a été mis sur la table donc
sur le premier pilier une étape clé a
été franchie vous faisiez allusion au
rapport de la task force de leaf rag que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présider
35 experts de 13 pays différents
comme je le disais tout à l'heure avant
cette réunion réunit uniquement en
virtuel neuf représentants des
institutions publiques qui ont à
connaître de ces questions-là plus
évidemment un secrétariat que j'ai
essayé d'organiser
à la hâte en septembre dernier cinq mois
de travail
un assez volumineux rapport 54
propositions qui ont été soumises à la
commission et qui travaille qui c'est
tout à l'honneur de la tasse fort dans
son ensemble a été salué pour sa qualité
et son dirait sa précision sur
l'ensemble des questions préparatoire le
socle d'une normalisation à venir on ne
nous demandait pas au niveau de la task
force de proposer des normes encore mais
on nous demandait de défricher le
terrain
et de préciser quels étaient les
paramètres à prendre en compte qu'elle
était larchitecture des standards que
l'on pouvait proposer et quelle était la
feuille de route pour un pour un
[Musique]
une livraison entre guillemets rapide
donc ce alors il y a eu énormément de
présentation je passe je passe de nous
avons eu par exemple en janvier cet
événement européen toujours en virtuel
dans cinq pays et de à bruxelles pour
les institutions européennes et nous
avons eu plus de 3000 participants dans
les webinaires que nous avons organisée
pour présenter les prêts conclusion de
la task force donc c'est un processus
très très rigoureux et relativement
relative et qui a et qui a suscité un
très grand intérêt parce qu'il y a une
véritable
comment dire je prêt à la fois pression
et une véritable avait une véritable
dynamique sur ces questions absolument
fondamental qui à mes yeux je l'avais
dit déjà en 2019 dans le rapport que
vous évoquez qui à mon avis quand pour
objet de constituer la deuxième jambe de
l'information de l'entreprise sur
elle-même à destination des tiers qui
est l'information sur la durabilité
puisque c'est le terme possibles pour
pour la traduction française de ce stade
habilité reporting troisième point le
président de les frags jean paul gauzès
a dans les mêmes délais c'est-à-dire fin
février remis un rapport avec ses
propositions pour créer au sein de les
frags une deuxième jambe
aussi ayant pour compétence cette
élaboration des standards je précise
tout de suite que à la différence de ce
qui se passe dans certains pays dans
certains autres pays dans certains
certaines autres zones les standards
reste sous le contrôle politique puisque
il est prévu que les frags
si le projet va jusqu'à son terme
élabore les standards mais les transmets
mes les transmettent à la commission qui
aura alors la responsabilité 2 adoptée
par actes délégués
donc on est sous l'orbité sous
l'ombrelle public ce qui est politique
ce qui me paraît absolument essentiel
donc voilà alors ce donc tout ça aboutit
comme je vous le disais fin avril à
l'adoption du
du projet de directive qui a changé de
nom elle s'appelle désormais csrd
corporate sustainability reporting
directive parce que nous avions fait la
remarque d'ailleurs dans notre rapport
je dis tout de suite que enfin il y a
nous y avions nous avions un dialogue
très très constant avec la commission
donc nous avons pu débattre de nos les
différences de point de vue parce que le
groupe de travail j'ai mentionné son
origine géographique mais son origine
aussi par professionnelle ou d'intérêt
étaient totalement à lui à l'image de
l'europe c'est-à-dire fondé sur un
équilibre des différentes
représentations possible et donc nous
avions dit le terme non financiers ne
nous paraît pas porter parce qu'il
définit les choses parce que ce que
parce que cela n'est pas est ce qu'il ne
serait pas mieux d'adopter une
terminologie positive et de parler de
d'information de performance durable
voilà et donc le la commission je pense
qu'elle était déjà assez prête à cela
mais il a été finalement convaincu et
donc le terme est devenu corporate
sustainability reporting
voilà alors il y a eu un événement
européen le 6 mai au cours de laquelle
la commissaire mairead mcguinness avait
rassemblé beaucoup de gens
et j'ai eu l'occasion de présenter les
grandes conclusions du rapport il et il
a été immédiatement dit il faut pendant
que le processus législatif se déroule
il faut que l'élaboration des normes se
développe car l'ambition de la csrd et
de rendre et de demander aux entreprises
pour simplifier de plus de 250 salariés
en europe ce qui veut dire environ 50000
entité de faire rapport
un rapport de 2 sustainability au
printemps 2000 24 / par référence à
l'année
2023 et pour cela la directive envisage
un premier jeu de normes applicables
publié en octobre 2022 dans le domaine
de la normalisation c'est demain matin
c'est à dire que c'est un très gros
travail si on fait les choses
sérieusement
et le cycle de préparation des normes
est souvent considéré enfin moins de 12
mois n'est pas possible 15 mois est un
véritable challenge
et souvent ces groupes plus long donc là
en l'occurrence nous sommes confrontés
est tout à fait positif à cet égard je
l'avais j'avais entre guillemets indiqué
la commissaire que je pensais que
c'était possible sous certaines
conditions de ressources
évidemment mais c'est c'est le challenge
dans lequel nous sommes engagés donc les
frags reprend entre guillemets du
service et votre serviteur aussi pour
commencer l'élaboration des normes
là nous avons notre miss notre réunion
de lancement la semaine prochaine j'ai
contacté personnellement
individuellement les 35 membres de la
task force pour leur demander s'ils
reprenaient du service ce sont des gens
qui ont des responsabilités dans les
organisations de rattachement
et à part deux ou trois meilleurs un
petit 10 % j'ai pour des raisons
personnelles et avec regret ils ont
cliqué qu'ils m'ont indiqué qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas à reprendre j'ai eu au
contraire un intérêt très grand et un
enthousiasme très grand donc
donc voila nous redémarrons dans le même
temps les frags va mettre en place sa
gouvernance là il faut changer là les
statuts de l'organisation qui est une
social sion internationale sans but
lucratif de droit belge
ça prend un peu de temps il faut ensuite
faire les appels à candidatures pour
déterminer les organes spécifiques
donc il y à un certain nombre de
procédures et on s'attend on attend la
mise en place de tout cela pour le
premier trimestre 2010 22 ce qui veut
dire que la deuxième phase de la task
force va se dérouler entre maintenant et
le premier trimestre 2012 date à
laquelle il y aura une à passage de
relais aux institutions modifiée de les
frags
évidemment la procès de les procédures
de normalisation vont être déterminé
avant et on va travailler de façon
provisoire sur les bases qui seront nous
l'espérons adopter s'il ya des
modifications mais on fera les
compléments nécessaires mais mais c'est
un processus qui est quand même
relativement relativement bien connu
donc voilà alors ça c'est le panorama
européen donc une véritable un véritable
mouvement
je n'ai pas évoqué le font encore donc
peut-être pour les questions je
répondrai au fond de la deûle ambitions
européennes en matière de d'informations
sûres sur la performance durable sur le
panorama international
en fait si je simplifie je dirais que il
y a deux grands mouvements qui se
dessine il y a le mouvement européen que
je viens de décrire et qui a des
caractéristiques très forte
la première caractéristique c'est
d'aller vers un système obligatoire
on n'est pas dans une adoption
volontaire la deuxième caractéristique
c'est qu'on a une couverture très large
de l'environnement du social sociétal et
de la gouvernance en ce compris
le devoir de vigilance la duke et lee
jones l'anti corruption et c'est donc
une vision vraiment assez large de ces
questions de durabilité
ça c'est la deuxième caractéristique la
troisième caractéristique vous l'avez
mentionné monsieur le président c'est la
double matérialité qui est absolument
fondamental dans la démarche européenne
et je sais que la france y est très
attaché donc nous sommes parfaitement en
harmonie sur ce sur ce point comme jeu
comme sur beaucoup d'autres et donc là
un vrai un vrai une vraie une vraie
différence
la quatrième caractéristique
fondamentale c'est que l'audit entre
guillemets la cieux ce qu'on appelle
l'assurance sera retire de tous les
intervenants de tous les intervenants
donc une intervention l'intervention
d'un tiers pour déterminer quelle est la
qualité d'information donc on va vers
une information normes et de qualité est
large et public et pas du tout l'apanage
d'organisation qui les collectent et qui
les distribue la distribution ou
l'analyse se fera certes mais sur une
base qui devrait en principe être à la
fois proche de la source c'est-à-dire
l'entreprise est certifiée par la
gouvernance et les tiers de l'entrée les
organismes tiers relatifs à l'eau eau
qui font le contrôle
donc voilà ça c'est un mouvement c'est
un mouvement qui se dessine est
internationalement vous avez d'ailleurs
au delà de l'europe des gens qui sont
assez proches de ces de ces mouvements
là notamment dans les organisations non
gouvernementales et qui sont donc très
proches de cette vision
européenne je pense notamment à la
global reporting initiative ou à un
organisme qui s'appelle shift sur les
droits de l'homme ou wiki sur les
intangible sur l'immatériel
donc il ya une possibilité d'une très
forte possibilité de co construction
et puis il ya un autre un autre
mouvement qui se dessine et qui essaie
de se mettre en place vous il y avait
fait allusion qui est celui qui se
concentre sur la matérialité financière
c'est-à-dire le risque pour les
entreprises et pas vraiment le risque
pas en tout cas à titre premier le
risque que l'entreprise fait courir à
son environnement au sens environnement
et au sens sociétal qui a pour objet de
travailler de façon première sur un
système assez pragmatique et assez en
épaisseur relativement plus faible que
celui qui ambitionne l'europe avec une
priorité sur le climat est entre
guillemets des étapes ultérieures peut
déterminer encore possible comme
possible mais simplement vu comme un
comme une possibilité
et donc ce deuxième mouvement
effectivement regroupe à la fois des
intervenants privés d'origine
britannique
enfin plus étant localisés en grande
bretagne ou aux états unis
je pense au ssb je pense à l'itrc je
pense également aux cds b qui a
longtemps travaillé sur le sur
l'empreinte carbone donc tout ça est
effectivement en cours
la co-construction l'europe a tendu la
main à ces gens à ces organisations en
leur disant écoutez c'est une c'est un
mouvement très fort émergents il ya des
ambitions différentes et des rythmes
différents mais ça n'interdit pas de
considérer les zones
co construction donc la position
européenne celle qui était d'ailleurs
dans le dans le rapport de la task force
comme il se retrouve dans le projet de 2
deux directives l'idée c'est fondamental
c'est de dire il y a une véritable
émergence il faut plutôt rassembler les
ressources travailler en intelligence
que d'essayer d'être en compétition et
donc c'est une stratégie l'europe à une
stratégie du et c'est à dire travailler
sur les impératifs européens et essayer
de contribuer à la convergence globale
et pas une stratégie du ou qui était qui
est celle qui a prévalu pour
l'information financière vous y faisiez
allusion monsieur le président
donc nous sommes en plein en pleine
discussion j'ai des conversations qui
était officieuse et qui maintenant
deviennent un peu plus officiel avec les
intervenants et nous cherchons tous
j'espère de bonnes de bonne de bonne
composition à faire en sorte que le
panorama ne soit pas un panorama de
compétition de compétition mais au
contraire de coopération je voudrais
dire que je voudrais dire que dans le
second courant que j'évoquais il y a à
l'évidence deux tendances
il y a une grande interrogation qui est
celle de savoir ce que les autorités
américaines vont faire à l'époque de
l'administration précédente
il n'y avait pas trop d'hésitation
c'était plutôt le désintérêt j'irai
affichée avec la nouvelle administration
démocrate
les choses ont beaucoup changé comme
vous le savez les états unis ont
réintégré la corde paris mais dans le
dans le domaine des normes financières
l'histoire nous a montré que après avoir
tenté de converger vers des normes dites
global
ils se sont en fait retirer de cette
convergence et donc il y as je pense une
vraie question pour savoir si le courant
que j'évoquais de matérialité financière
sera unitaire ou double c'est à dire
avec une version américaine est une
version plus plus internationale
fortement appuyé probablement par par
les britanniques eux
et comment ce ce calibre rompt les
relations entre le courant que
j'appellerais le courant européen
l'éventuelle courant américain et le
courant plus internationale voilà je ne
pense pas que la fin à ce stade il me
paraît difficile compte tenu de
l'importance du sujet et des différences
culturelles qui est de juridiction et de
systèmes légaux
je pense qu'il est impossible
aujourd'hui d'envisager une unicité
absolue en revanche il est tout à fait
utile de promouvoir une convergence
peut-être j'étais un peu long monsieur
le président je vous prie de m'excuser
mais je vais peut-être maintenant me
livrer à vous à vos questions merci
monsieur le président pour ce propos
liminaire mais déjà très très précis et
ouvrant les voies de l'avenir je vais
passer depuis d'abord la parole à
jacques launay qui qui est que je vois
en visio et qui était co rédacteur du
rapport sénatorial avec notre collègue
elisabeth lamure à l'époque pas si
lointaine puisque c'était en juin 2020
sur ce sujet des normes pour les
entreprises donc je lui passe la parole
jacques oui merci président dans son
rapport en effet nous avions souligné
que la conception renouvelée de
l'entreprise devait prendre en compte le
temps long or la vision qui domine
actuellement les normes comptables
plutôt ça les investisseurs de court
terme sur le sur les marchés financiers
et dans ce rapport nous indiquions que
seules les informations financières
étaient prises en considération et que
les informations sociales ou
environnementales et hd7 côté c'est
diffusion d'informations sont pas
neutres car elle façonne bien entendu la
manière dont sont dirigés gérer nos
entreprises sur le président de combourg
pour les neuf ou faire part de votre
avis sur cette réflexion et j'aurai des
questions un peu plus précis ça vous
posez sans être parce que vous avez déjà
répondu à un certain nombre de points
mais tout d'abord l'accueil sanitaires
économiques at elle selon vous ralentit
les démarches et restent les entreprises
le risque d'un standard privé de
l'information non financières est il
aujourd'hui écartée selon vous et enfin
plus d'une manière un peu plus plus
précise quels sont les apports de
règlement taxonomie comment sont cassés
les activités gazières et pétrolières du
bar et nucléaire d'autre part et enfin
une dernière question jusqu'où
descendant la granularité de
l'information non financières les hôtes
et les pme de plus de 500 salariés les
aime plus petits voilà quelques
questions que je voulais vous poser en
remerciant merci monsieur le sénateur
rapidement tout d'abord effectivement
l'idée fondamentale et d'introduire une
vision de long terme c'est à dire de
développement durable dans la gestion
des entreprises dans sa relation avec
les tiers donc c'est bien ça l'objectif
je confirme
lors de l'audition que j'ai eu l'honneur
de d'avoir avec vous et madame la mûre
je crois que j'avais déjà souligné ce
point et je le confirme donc c'est bien
l'ambition la crise sanitaire
j'ai une gêne vision qui est la suivante
évidemment à court terme il peut y avoir
des préoccupations fondée sur l'urgence
en revanche je constate qu'un certain
nombre d'entreprises n'ont absolument
pas baisser la garde en matière de
l'information fait de démarche rse et je
pense que la plupart contre la pandémie
a aussi souligné la nécessité d'élargir
les critères de décision au sein des
entreprises
pas facile mais donc il peut y avoir un
léger ralentissement opérationnel mais
je pense qu'au contraire la crise a
rendu absolument incontournable la
question rse en tout cas dans la
perception de la d'une grande partie des
des des chefs d'entreprise les en tout
cas les plus mobilisées jeu j'ai
beaucoup de contacts avec des
entreprises aujourd'hui et je constate
que l'urgence d'avancées dans sur ces
domaines est assez largement partagé
alors peut-être pas par tout le monde
peut-être que le rythme est jugé trop
rapide pour par certains ce qui est tout
à fait possible
trop long par d'autres mais mais en
revanche l'évolution enfin je n'ai
absolument aucun doute sur l'évolution
son rythme peut être variable peut
varier peut-être un peu la destination
est clair la vitesse elle est un peu
moins et la consistance est à est à
discuter mais en revanche l'orientation
générale
pas de doute alors le risque d'un
standard privée je dirais qu'avec le
risque il existe toujours c'est toujours
un danger il faut pas se tromper
donc je pense que ce n'est il n'y a pas
d' on ne peut pas écarter de façon
définitive et
ma vision de la chose c'est que pour les
cartés il faut être bon en europe il
faut il faut converger mettre des
ressources faire des efforts la
normalisation ça n'est pas très cher en
revanche elle n'est pas considérée comme
une zone d'investissement en revanche
c'est en tout cas pas suffisamment c'est
une zone d'investissement peu
d'investissement peu cher et à un retour
extrêmement élevé chacun comprendra
l'importance stratégique de comptes de
conserver l'initiative de l'écriture en
matière de normes et si je vous dis
qu'un normalisateurs européen ça coûte
10 millions d'euros 15 millions d'euros
par an peut-être dans le meilleur des
cas 20 millions que la fondation yves
férès tourne aujourd'hui avec 30
millions mais fait beaucoup de travail
de training de d'éducation de relations
etc
le la normalisation en tant que tel ça
n'est pas très cher condom quand on voit
les plans de relance un peu partout il
me paraîtrait assez logique que l'on
mette une infime partie de tout ça sur
une donnée c'est un élément stratégique
immatériel intangible mais clés voilà
pardon je plaide un peu aussi devant le
celui des indes est un des toners des
cordons de la bourse mais voilà je le
dis voilà je le dis je vous rassure je
le dis aussi à un gouvernement je suis
président d'une autorité je me permets
de le dire avec avec liberté alors
taxonomie jeu s'ils voulaient c'est un
sujet c'est un sujet complexe
je pense est une très bonne démarche
elle a besoin en revanche de trouver un
socle de données solides parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est compliqué je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas je vais dire
encore l'objectif est de faire en sorte
que le règlement csrd c'est à dire qu'il
va établir la normalisation des données
servent bien de base aux décisions qui
sont et qui sont inscrits seront
inspirés par les critères convenus dans
le cadre de la taxonomie est là si vous
voulez on rentre dans un point qui est
assez délicat c'est celui de la
classification des activités
classification des activités je sais je
connais bien le responsable de la de la
plateforme qui gère ces questions là au
plan européen
je sais qu'ils ont eux mêmes leurs
propres débats sur que doit-on
caractériser des activités comme étant
des activités renouvelables auquel cas
le pourcentage risque d'être faible
ou doit-on favoriser la transition c'est
à dire une évolution avec le temps et si
oui comment
donc c'est un sujet que nous allons que
nous avons clairement introduite qui
nous est fixé d'ailleurs par le projet
de directive le projet directive nous
dit il ya au moins trois choses que vous
devez faire c'est vous devez être
cohérent avec la taxonomie vous devez de
cohérent avec le règlement disclosure
sfd est requis les gestionnaires
d'actifs sont aujourd'hui et les
institutions financières sont
aujourd'hui à la peine parce qu'on leur
demande des informations alors que les
informations dont ils ont besoin pour
bâtir ces informations sont pas
nécessairement disponibles donc il faut
que la csr des nourrices ce flux
d'informations et troisième élément
qu'il l'a est plus une question de
priorité on nous dit la tcf des sur le
climat a quand même aujourd'hui un bon
niveau d'acceptation internationale il
faut se situer dans ce mouvement là
quitte à aller un peu plus loin si on
doit mettre de la matte double
matérialité dedans encore que pour le
climat les les
la double matérialité et un peu complexe
parce que si on réfléchit vraiment la
tcf d'aidantes et cfd le f veut dire
financial disclosures mais en fait on
part quand même d'un sujet
environnemental d'abord et on ne connaît
pas encore le cheminement des
conséquences financières donc
paradoxalement c'est une
nous la double matérialité et assez
entremêlés j'en profite pour dire que
sur la double matérialité nous nous
pensons fondamentalement dans la tasse
force au niveau de la csrd qu' il n'est
pas possible d'avoir une approche
financière sol en fait parfois les
approches financières d'ailleurs son
sont mixtes hybride mais elle ne le
disent pas nous nous pensons que l'on
doit regarder chaque phénomène qui
affecte soit l'entreprise soit la
société et l'environnement en même temps
et de vérifier l'intensité du risque ou
de l'opportunité qui en découlent pour
l'entreprise et pour la société est
d'ailleurs ces intensités peuvent varier
avec le temps et peut quelque chose qui
au départ est totalement du domaine de
l'extra financier peut un jour devenir
financier si les législateurs par
exemple décide que le carbone ya une
taxe carbone ou des choses comme ça
voyez donc donc les conséquences
financières sont parfois diffuse
peut-être ténue ou en formation et donc
elles vont elles peuvent monter en
puissance en raison de l'importance du
facteur environnemental social de
l'impact sur de l'entreprise sur
l'extérieur donc il faut traiter cette
question là comme une vis dans une
vision holistique
enfin sur le seuil je le disais tout à
l'heure
monsieur le sénateur
c'est ce sont les entreprises telles que
définies comme grandes entreprises dans
le règlement comptable européen c'est à
dire les entreprises qui répondent à
deux des trois critères suivants plus de
40 millions de chiffre d'affaires plus
de 20 millions de total de bilan ou plus
de 250 salariés
donc on a on abaisse largement on est on
est au delà des 500 qui était prévu à la
la c'est à la haine frd et donc on passe
la population qui était visé en europe
était
de 2002 ou trois mille dans l'haleine fr
des certains pays dont la france sont
accrus l'omi des seuils plus bas mais on
passe à près de 50 milles au niveau
européen et ça représente une part
importante de la création de valeur est
par ailleurs j'ajoute les entreprises
les pme seront encouragés à adopter un
système établi pour elle volontairement
et il y a une probabilité qu'il y est
une sorte de cercle vertueux car ce
système simplifié pour les pme qu'il
nous est demandé de préparer évidemment
constituera le socle de la demande des
institutions financières quand elle
finance ou des grandes entreprises quand
elles quand elles ont la pme pour
fournisseurs ou pour clients voilà donc
on ne s'avance vraiment c'est une
avancée à mon avis assez fondamentale
progressive mesure et proportionnée bon
je je je trouve que les options qui ont
été prises on va voir ce qui résulte du
processus législatif mais sont
relativement équilibrés
il ya peut-être besoin de réglages mais
mais globalement assez assez voilà
j'espère avoir répondu à votre ktm 4
question monsieur le sénateur merci
monsieur le président simplement une
question de précision je sais pas j'ai
pas été attentifs à ce moment là c'est
le caractère cumulatif ou non des
critères pour la sélectivité des
entreprises concernées ces deux des 3 2
des 3 ok merci
alors on va passer aux questions dans la
salle il ya plusieurs critères aussi
qu'ils sont cumulatifs chez nous il ya
celui du temps et puis la durée des
questions dont je vais vous demander aux
trois collègues successivement de poser
vos questions le président les prendre a
globalement pour aller vers sa
conclusion puisque ce sera l'occasion de
terminer de cette façon
donc je successivement didier mandelli
il chaque année et martin berthet à
l'oral poser vos questions
successivement puis le président froid
le réponse très bien merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président de
combat vous avez évoqué la possible que
l'existence d'un de deux systèmes de
standard entre les états unis et le
reste du monde entre guillemets est ce
que vous considérez aujourd'hui que
qu'il existe encore un risque d'un
standard privé de l'information non
financières ou ce risque et il écarté
selon vous aujourd'hui de deuxième
question vous l'avez évoqué également
donc peut-être dans votre et repensé
avec un peu plus de précisions sur la
fusion dont deux liés à ces et de la ssb
pour devenir donc la value sporting
foundation cette organisation unifiée
viserait à fournir aux investisseurs aux
entreprises un référentiel exhaustif
sait gérer ce stade du dernier acte de
recomposition des acteurs de la
normalisation
comment l'analysez-vous même si vous
avez en partie répondu et puis dernière
question là encore vous l'avez évoqué la
double maternité est ce qui est
important pour nous et pour les
entreprises c'est quelle est la valeur
ajoutée ou la plus value pour les
entreprises que confère cette double
matérialité michel canevet merci chez le
président de questions d'une part
comment appréhendez vous la prise en
compte de ces questions dans les autres
pays européens
en france on sait que la loi pacte
orienté beaucoup vers la région mais y
at-il une prise de conscience selon vous
dans les autres pays européens
une seconde question c'est la question
de l'audit
comment pourra-t-on être assurés que les
européens prennent le litre sur le sujet
je pense en particulier aux questions de
certification dans le domaine médical où
on voit que bien souvent ce sont des
acteurs étrangers auxquels doivent se
soumettre nos startups avec les risques
d'évasion des savoir faire qui sont
libres dans la matière
et ceci est particulièrement dramatique
parce qu'on n'a pas su nous ressaisir de
cela et c'est l'un des facteurs qui fait
que dans notre pays on n'arrive pas
suffisamment faire valoir les questions
médicales
est ce qu'il n'ya pas le risque qu'il y
ait la même chose avec les audits de
certification qui soit demandée dans le
cas présent merci martin berthet pour
troisième série de questions oui
monsieur le président donc nous
travaillons actuellement sur un rapport
qui concerne l'évolution des modes de
travail et de management et notamment
cette évolution accélérée que nous avons
vu sur cette dernière année du
télétravail est ce que cela ces
évolutions vous obligez modifier les
axes que vous aviez prévu pour votre
rapport notamment sur les
classifications
qu'est ce que cela a entraîné pour vous
voilà monsieur le président une série de
questions vous reste un quart d'heure
sur la question de la cohabitation 20 du
risque du standard privée et de la
cohabitation de différents systèmes
bon si vous voulez nous sommes sur un
paysage qui est en pleine en plaine
j'avais pas dire recomposition mais en
pleine consolidation et évolution en
fait l'émergence avec l'europe
d'ailleurs en position pionnières
l'émergence de l'information de
performance durable comme une donnée
fondamentale de la gestion des
entreprises et de sa relation avec les
tiers conduit de toute façon aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un monde où il manque
des ressources c'est dans ce domaine et
donc en fait des acteurs cherchent et
c'est assez naturel dans un monde ouvert
à renforcer se renforcer et promouvoir
leur vision
voilà donc comme je voulais dit le
standard privé il faut toujours faire
attention et en fait pour que pour en
écarter le risque ou pour le en faire
l'un des acteurs mais pas le seul acteur
il faut être nous-mêmes européens
français il faut que nous soyons
performants
c'est à dire que nous passions du
domaine de l'ambition au domaine de la
réalisation pratique et donc on revient
d'ailleurs indirectement aux questions
de ressources et d'amplitude des
ressources dont on a besoin
alors vous avez mentionné rapidement la
fusion sas brc vous avez parlé de
dernier acte pour moi c'est plutôt un
premier acte dans ce dans ce courant ce
sont des gens que je connais est
relativement bien avec qui j'ai un
dialogue constructif
il faut savoir que ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui même après la fusion la
value reporting lines
ça n'est pas du tout un système complet
pourquoi et c'est insisté en disant cela
je ne suis pas nécessairement critique
du tout par rapport à ce que à ce que
ceux qui le font parce que chacun
apporte sa pierre à l'édifice mais ssb
est une démarche très pragmatique
nord-américaine qui est parti de l'idée
qu'il fallait commencer par une vision
sectorielle de l'économie c'est-à-dire
la comparaison entre des pères dans un
même secteur
ils ont défini onze grands secteurs 77
ou secteur et ils ont réuni les gens en
leur disant qu est ce qui est
significatif sur le com risque pour
l'entreprise alors c'est la matérialité
financière qu'est ce qui est
significatif pour les entreprises dans
ces secteurs ils ont réuni des
spécialistes
les spécialistes ont dit ah ben voilà
selon nous c'est ça donc c'est une sorte
de consensus de marché sur ce qui est
important et on aboutit à 13
informations en moyenne par entreprise
sectorielle donc c'est vous dire que la
profondeur d' analyse est relativement
intéressante mais c'est vraiment une
toute première étape et ils sont dans le
spectre de l'organisation de la
normalisation sur le créneau sectorielle
ils viennent de fusionner avec l'itrc
lierse et c'est l'autre bout du spectre
ça n'est pas un normalisateurs c'est un
organisme qui développe des principes de
management qui s'appelle le rapport
intègre et intégrer les différentes
dimensions d'une gestion d'entreprise
pour en donner une bonne image et qui
des plats et qui travaille sur ce qu'on
appelle la connectivité
et à la relation entre l'information
financière et les autres formes
d'informations pour donner une vision
cohérente et complète de l'entreprise
ce sont des principes excellent mais en
revanche quand vous lisez la littérature
les demandes sont très principe yale et
ça tient en 25 pages donc si vous voulez
vous et ils sont à l'autre bout du
spectre
donc il n'ya pas au centre dans cette
démarche là encore la partie générique
qu'on appelle en anglais secteur
agnostique de l'information donc pour
moi c'est un des premiers actes et pas
du tout le dernier
et puis la double matérialité y at il un
intérêt pour les entreprises
oui fondamentale pour moi l'entreprise
aujourd'hui quand elles intègrent les
préoccupations environnementales
sociales et de gouvernance dans sa
gestion elle gère mieux 1 2 elle crée
des relations de confiance avec
l'ensemble ces parties prenantes
c'est fondamental et 3 jeux les vues de
façon évidente même à une ampleur que je
ne soupçonnais pas attirer des capitaux
pour son développement pour cette pour
financer ces transitions à des coûts
meilleure
donc on est sur trois avantages
compétitifs fondamentaux pour les
entreprises sur la position des autres
pays européens ont comme toujours en
europe
si vous voulez je pense que je pense que
la dynamique au parlement européen est
assez forte en faveur du même très forte
en faveur du
2 de la serbie et des autres
réglementations
certains pays sont plus sont plus
réservés mais j'observe avec grande
attention je dirais les grands acteurs
lorsque nous avons conduit nos activités
de relations avec les tiers où nous
avons organisé ces webinaire les sept
webinaire que j'évoquais on a eu du
monde partout vraiment partout et plutôt
avec des questions positive
le record a été battu en espagne où nous
avions près de 1000 participants au
webinaire alors qu'en france on en avait
6 ans donc évidemment la france l'italie
a été très bien avec 400 etc en
allemagne on a eu plutôt à un public
plus restreint mais de spécialistes
comme souvent en allemagne des gens qui
connaissent bien le sujet qui se sont
intéressés qui ont posé des questions
très techniques
l'allemagne est peut-être préoccupé par
le rythme peut-être mais à mon avis pas
vraiment par la direction
à terme elle préfère aussi compte tenu
de l'internationalisation d'un certain
nombre d'affaires allemande sans doute
elle préfère qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
divergences avec les courants
internationaux
de ce point de vue là je dis toujours
que l'international sera une un niveau
basique et que le niveau européen sera
au moins aussi bon si ce n'est meilleur
mais très certainement en tout cas
l'ambition est bien plus élevé et que
donc il n'y aura pas incompatibilité
il y aura complémentarité voilà l'eau
dit oui alors l'audit est un plus mais
effectivement il est important que
l'europe se saisisse de la question que
michel barnier avait vous les avez voulu
traiter au moment de la réforme de
l'audit et qu'il n'y était à vrai dire
il n'y est pas parvenu de son propre
aveu c'est d'ailleurs la question des
diversifications
il est éminemment souhaitable et
peut-être savez vous que je viens d'une
organisation indépendante gérée pendant
longtemps une organisation indépendante
qui a fait son chemin dans ce domaine là
et chemin qui reste à parfaire mes
successeurs s'y attachent mais
il faut favoriser la diversification de
l'offre et il faut européaniser autant
que faire se peut les acteurs qui sont
dans des grands réseaux internationaux
parce que je pense que c'est une bonne
chose il faut qu'il réponde à mes yeux
où je dirais aux caractéristiques
culturelles qui sont en train de se
développer et qui sont la marque d'une
identité européenne
enfin madame la sénatrice sur
l'évolution des modes de travail et de
management
oui c'est un élément très clé il n'y a
plus il y a s'ils voulaient nous avons
lorsque nous avons défini les sujets que
nous suggérions de traité nous avons
fini par nous rattacher nous avons
discuté ce qu'il ya six catégories 5 4
watts et nous avons fini par nous
rattacher quelque chose qui est connue
qui est le sg environnement social qui
en anglais veut dire sociétale et g mais
nous l'avons appelé j'ai plus alors voir
c'est un petit truc de communication
parce que nous voulions
si vous voulez mettre l'accent dans
l'environnement sur la relation de
l'entreprise avec la planète
ces grands mots mais bon voilà nous
voulions mettre dans le esse la relation
l'accent sur la relation avec les
personnes et dans le g plus nous
voulions travailler sur tout ce que la
personne morale à la tête d'un groupe
l'entreprise peut apporter par la
savante combinaison des facteurs de
production soient physiques soient
humains facteurs de production je n'aime
pas tellement ce terme mais bon les
ressources que l'on mène que l'on met en
oeuvre et dans ce j'ai plus nous avons
mis l'accent sur l'immatériel
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intangible
parce que c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas reflété dans la formation financière
l'information développement durable est
souvent vue sous un angle punitif c'est
à dire quels sont les risques que l'on
fait courir mais il ya du positif
beaucoup de positif donc il faut aussi
refléter ce positif est la question que
vous évoquez sur les méthodes de
management et de
de travail et est au coeur de cette
disposition là donc nous avons une
rubrique nous proposition de proposons
un sou sujet sous j'ai plus qui
s'appelle organisation et à vrai dire
quand on voit comment les entreprises
sont confrontées aujourd'hui à cette
problématique du télétravail donc et de
la répartition entre le présentiel et le
distant ciel c'est un truc clé avec des
conséquences sur l'immobilier avec les
conséquences bien entendu sur la vie des
gens sur le mélange avec la vie
personnelle sur le las le caractère
privé des données etc etc sur la
l'infrastructure technique vraiment il
ya beaucoup de questions
voilà et si vous me permettez un mot
peut-être de conclusion je dirais que
nous sommes nous sommes vraiment à un
moment clé jeu
vous remercie d'avoir pris le temps de
de cet échange parce que cela démontre
que
vous accorder beaucoup d'importance à
cette question et à juste titre parce
que nous sommes vraiment aux moments
stratégiques où l'europe peut être un
émetteur de normes
je pense que l'europe qui s'est battue
qui s'est battu pour se créer sur la
diversité ne peut pas vouloir déployer
enfin c'est pas dans la halle dans la
dans la dans le code génétique de
l'europe de vouloir déployer une
solution nécessairement mondiale
hégémonique mais en revanche l'europe a
certainement une possibilité et la
france est au premier au premier rang
pour développer une position de
d'inspiration et de leadership dans ce
dans ce domaine en espérant entraîner
beaucoup de gens dans son sillage voilà
merci beaucoup je suis président nous
allons suivre avec intérêt vous avez vu
qu'il ya plusieurs collègues engager
vraiment sur ces sujets donc qui vont
suivre tout cela avec précision nous
ferons des rapports et des tapes et
peut-être aurons-nous l'occasion en
laissant un petit peu autant l'occasion
de permettre le développement de tout
cela de refaire le point avec vous dans
quelques dans quelques mois je suis à
votre disposition sur le président et à
celle de la délégation évidemment merci
beaucoup bonne journée monsieur merci
merci beaucoup
[Musique]